DAVID NETTLETON: Hi then,
and welcome to this session
on where to store your stuff
with Google Cloud Platform.
My name is David Nettleton.
I'm a product manager
here at Google Cloud.
I've been here for
about four years now,
and I've been working on
storage throughout that time.
And what I'd like to do today is
cover two main topics, really.
So first of all, just maybe
stand back a little bit
and go through a history
of how storage has evolved,
how databases have evolved, and
then walk through from there
some of the options that
are available in Google
Cloud for storing your data.
Before I get to that, though,
a quick safe-harbor statement.
Just to remind folks that some
of the announcements that I
talk about in here
are forward looking
and bear in mind from a
safe-harbors perspective.
So first of all, let me start
with a history of storage.
And if I go back
30, 40, 50 years,
the way that storage
first came about
was really storage physically
attached to the computer,
right?
So on the left-hand
side here, there's
this notion of sort of
direct-attached storage.
Storage is physically
attached to the computer
that you're using.
The storage is really
there only to be
used for the local machine.
And as the local data, and it's
all very physically connected,
often into a single piece
of hardware with a monitor
that somebody would then sit at.
And we're going back
a long way for this,
but this is classic
direct-attached storage.
Also, a common PC would
also look like this as well.
But then as people
wanted to think
about sharing their
data more, they
started to think about what
does data and storage look
like over a network?
And this evolved in a
number of different ways.
So one way in which this
evolved is to take a storage,
move just the storage
over a network,
leave the file system local
to the machine or the computer
on which you are using,
and have block storage be
remote over the network.
Block storage was
the preferred model
here because it would give
good remote performance.
The file system would be
local on the computer.
It would use large block
sizes, 8K, 16k block sizes,
or even larger, 64K,
to communicate remotely
over the network sending large
I/O requests to bring data
back and forward,
and it would cache
what it would need locally.
And this really was the area of
sort of storage area networks
where companies could start
to consolidate storage
from individual machines,
started consolidated
into a central pool of
storage, and managed
high-performance block
storage centrally
and deliver it to the
applications that needed it
over the network.
So that was pretty good for
some of the high-performance use
cases where you need the local
performance on the machine,
but what it didn't
work so well is
is if you wanted to share
files between different users
in an organization.
And for that, the
classic file share
of the network-attached
storage was the storage option
that evolved for that.
So it's file storage, file
sharing over a network.
Here, the file system is remote.
It's across the network
from the compute
or the application
that's using it.
And the file system is
available to all users
to be able to connect to
it, use it, and share it.
That's great from a
sharing perspective.
One of the challenges
with that, though,
is as customers start to--
as users in an organization
start to share and
use many files,
then lots of complexities
start to arise in terms
of who can access what file.
Who's allowed to read it?
Who can write it?
What are the
permissions around that?
And then managing
folders and hierarchies
and scaling the
metadata storage means
building large-scale,
scalable, high-performance file
systems is a really big,
hard, challenging problem
but super powerful in that
it's very easy to then share
file data between many
different applications.
So that was really how storage
evolved for very many years.
And then a final
class of storage
has emerged more
recently and actually
probably popularized
in the cloud
first and foremost,
which was object storage.
So here the goal is to
be able to store really
large amounts of
unstructured data.
So think videos or
pictures, images,
store it really cheaply and
at really, really large scale.
As I said, that's something
that really sort of came
to fruition in the
public cloud first where
customers would look
for a cheap, easy way
to store flexibly
large amounts of data
and then access it, often
occasionally, to get access
to that.
And this model made some
very big trade-offs, right?
It had a very simple API.
There wasn't a lot of sharing
between users of the data.
It's often append only.
And it made trade-offs
to be able to support
that storing large
amounts of data remotely
and being able to access
it in a very simple API.
And a new API, which
was the object API,
was brought about
in order to do that.
So if I'm at these sort of
different classes or types
of storage now to what is
available in the cloud,
the evolution of
the classic storage
being tightly coupled to the
application and the file system
and compute is available--
so this is classic block
storage-- is available in two
forms in Google Cloud Platform.
First of all, we have Persistent
Disk in a standard and SSD
format which lets
you remotely mount
a block-storage device or a
disk at your VM in Google Cloud
Platform.
A disk is durable, able to
withstand restarts of the VM,
and high performant.
In addition, we have
a product called
Local SSD which is
ephemeral storage,
is attached very much directly
to the actual physical compute
instance that is running.
So you can get much, much
higher performance from it,
but it's ephemeral.
So those are the two
block-storage solutions that we
have available in Google Cloud.
For network-attached
storage or a file share
where I want to have
a file share which
is shared in the department
or across my enterprise,
from Google Cloud we have
Google Cloud Filestore
as our first-party product.
And then we also work
closely with partners
such as NetApp, Dell EMC, in
particular their Isilon product
and DDN.
And these are
enterprise vendors who
have been working in the
area of file storage for very
many years now,
and many customers
have been working with them.
We want to make sure we can help
carry those customers forward
as they look to use those
products in the cloud.
And then for object storage
in Google Cloud, the product
we have there is
called Cloud Storage.
That's our
object-storage product
which lets you store data
at really large scale.
I'll go through in detail
some more on the Google Cloud
products that we have available
later in the presentation.
So let me also talk about
other places in Google Cloud
that you might--
or products in Google Cloud that
you might use to store data.
Let's talk about databases.
And so at a high level, for many
years the world of databases,
there was sort of a
very traditional model
that lasted for many years.
So it's sort of the
late '60s, '70s,
the classic relational
database where you would
store a record in a table.
A row would be
stored in a table,
and you can join it
together with other rows
and other tables.
Really introduced a very
powerful model for managing,
storing, and
reasoning about data.
And the traditional
relational-database-management
market grew to be a very,
very large business with IBM
and Oracle leading
the way and grew
into a very large, traditional,
on-premises industry.
The benefit of this was that
you could you really fast
reasoning over small amounts of
data, store it pretty quickly.
If you wanted to run large
queries for analytics,
do reporting or
run a dashboard, it
was normally pretty bad
practice to run those queries
against the same system
that's running your banking
application.
So quite often data would
be moved off of the database
system into a data warehouse
via a process known as ETL,
Extract, Transform, Load.
And data would be copied
over into a data warehouse.
It would be rearranged
in a particular way
to make it really easy to
do large-scale analytics
and reporting.
And that combination of
database and data warehouse
really has stood the test
of time for many years,
and it still remains the bastion
of many sort of enterprise
organizations' data storage
and analytics processes.
And so, really, that ecosystem
existed for a very long time.
And then over towards the
start of-- through the 2000s,
there was a whole number
of different trends
that started to affect how well
that ecosystem could scale.
So first and foremost was
the emergence of just really
large amounts of
unstructured data.
With more devices connected,
with the emergence
of the internet, with different
types of data being generated,
the traditional
relational-database management
system just simply
could not cope
with that amount
of storage anymore
and the amount of analytics
that needed to run over it.
So several types of
more specialized systems
started to emerge.
Probably one of the
most famous of those
is Hadoop, which is a
large-scale analytics
platform for
unstructured data that
lets you get a large amounts
of data really cheaply,
run large amounts of
batched processing over it,
and do analysis on that.
And that really
changed the dynamic
of how people thought
about doing analytics,
and there was a big debate.
Should I get rid of my
warehouse and put everything
in a data lake?
Or everything should
go in the data lake,
or everything goes
in my data warehouse.
And in reality, both
of these systems
are perfectly good at
working side by side,
and often customers
will store data
in a data lake for
their initial capture
and then load it eventually
into a warehouse.
But Hadoop came along as
a really interesting trend
and set of capabilities to help
customers more easily get value
out of their unstructured data.
Within the more semistructured
and structured world,
two other things also
happened as well.
So customers would
also look for, hey, I
got a really large amount of
sparse data, so key values.
I want to do lookups.
I'm gathering records of
data which is semistructured,
and I've got a really large
amount of it coming out
of my IoT system, for example.
Like cell-tower data is
pretty well structured.
There's 15, 16 different types
of data maybe in a record,
but that's evolving over time.
There's really large amounts of
sparse key-value lookup data.
And that, again,
is not something
that's particularly well suited
for a traditional database
system because of the scale
that it wants to operate at
and the cost trade-offs take
it in a slightly different
direction.
And then in addition,
we also saw the trend
to more semistructured
data storage, things
like being able to
store JSON documents
and do reasoning over those as
people started to capture data
in JSON formats.
And so they led to
another two types
of databases, which are
key-value databases and then
hierarchical databases as two
other kind of classic NoSQL
databases.
So this is the
category of databases
that they don't have often the
same deep traditional semantics
of the acid properties of a
traditional relational-database
management systems, and they're
willing to make trade-offs
in terms of their scale
and other factors in order
to better support reasoning
over different forms of data.
And then finally
and most recently,
we're also now seeing a class
of databases that are really
large scale, scale-out
relational-database management
system.
So the traditional
relational-database management
system is a scale-up system.
So you'll put your
database on a server.
You'll attach a load
of storage to it.
And if you want to
store more records
or you want to do
more compute, you've
got to add more processors
to that same machine,
or you've got to add more
disks to that array, right?
And so it was a classic
scale-up system.
And that runs into
some challenges.
Customers are buying
bigger and bigger systems
to operate at larger
and larger scale,
and that becomes very expensive
and not always very flexible
in terms of where
you can deploy that.
You can only deploy it
in a single location.
So now more recently there's
a class of database systems
which let you now store records
transactionally at global scale
and manage really large-scale
transactional database systems.
If I go through the
Google Cloud products that
are available across
this portfolio,
so first of all, the
traditional database
we have the Cloud
SQL set of products
for MySQL, Postgres,
and SQL Server that let
you run and manage a database.
BigQuery is our
data-warehouse product.
For a data lake, Google Cloud
Dataproc and Cloud Storage
give you Dataproc
for managing compute,
and Cloud Storage
is your data lake.
And then Bigtable provides
key-value storage files,
Filestore for hierarchical
data, and then Cloud Spanner
is our database for
really large-scale,
global transactional databases.
So with that overview
in mind, I just
thought I'd have a
slide that gives you
a rough mapping of the different
types of storage options
that are available
to you, depending
on what it is that
you are looking
to do with Google Cloud.
Now let me maybe
just dive into sort
of the ones that are
on the right side
there, the storage products.
So I'll leave the database
overviews to other sessions,
and I'm just going to
now concentrate and go
through some of the
storage options that
are available on GCP.
So first of all,
Google Cloud Storage.
So this is our large-scale
object-storage product.
Customers are normally using
this for three different use
cases.
So content storage
and delivery--
so if you want to store large
amounts of media, video,
images, and serve
them out to customers
or store them for
later analysis.
Google Cloud Storage is a
really great product for that.
Customers like Spotify use
this for storing and serving
media content, for example.
Backup, archival, DR--
so a very common use case
where you have a set
of data on premises
that you're looking to protect.
You want to store it
remotely on a different media
to protect yourself
against a disaster, either
a physical disaster or
someone accidentally
deleting some data
on premises, and you
want to be able to recover
it via a backup process.
And so Google Cloud
Storage is integrated
with very many backup and DR
products from our partners
and is available to use for
backup, archival, and DR.
And then the final use case is
analytics, big data, and ML.
So I talked about
the use case where
customers are wanting
to store really
large amounts of unstructured
data for processing,
and they want to
store that cheaply.
And the cloud is a
great place to do that.
They can use something
like Google Cloud Storage
to store the data super cheaply.
And then because
compute and storage
is separate from each other,
customers can store their data.
And when they want to run
a Hadoop cluster over it,
they can just spin
that cluster up,
run it for the amount of
time that it's needed,
and then shut it down.
And this is a huge value over
the alternative on premises,
which is often trying to
size compute and storage
together in a single
piece of equipment, often
having to deal with
planning for peak capacity
and then trying to run it to
make sure that in quiet times
that you're not
wasting capacity.
So it takes away a
lot of the challenges
with trying to optimize the
TCO for a cluster on premises.
So with the cloud, you can
separate compute from storage.
Use only what you
need on storage.
need for compute,
and run those independently.
And the product we have,
Google Cloud Storage,
super powerful for
those use cases.
A couple of things I'll
highlight there with this
is we have a number of different
tiers from Standard, Nearline,
Coldline, all the
way down to Archival.
And these just give
you different ways
to pay for how you
store your data.
Something that's really
interesting about the product
and very differentiated
is that across all
of those different
tiers, it's the same API
and the same access
speeds to the data.
So you don't need to change
anything in your application
to be able to take advantage
of tiering data down
to cheaper and cheaper
storage classes
if the data just
needs to be accessed.
But if all of a
sudden that kitten
movie that was super
popular five years ago
suddenly picks up
again, well, it's
right there immediately
available for access
even if it might be
in an archive tier.
There's no staging it back
from a different storage
product that has
to bring it back
to take a few hours to stage
it back to your main storage
tiers.
So that's a couple of benefits
for storage in general.
And then a few other things
specific to use cases.
So we have for common
storage and delivery,
we globally edge cache data
and accelerate uploads.
So data coming in from
Europe and stored in the US.
We'll bring it onto the
Google Cloud network
as soon as possible and
carry it on the network
for as long as possible
until we serve it.
For big data and
analytics, for Hadoop,
all of the different readers
in GCS will see the same data.
So one of the great features
of Google Cloud Storage
is that it actually
uses Spanner,
which I talked about
is a transactionally
consistent database to
store all of our metadata.
So when somebody writes
data, everybody else
can see the same data, which
is a big benefit for Google's
product here.
That's actually
pretty hard to do
and something that's
super powerful.
And then as I talked about
a little bit earlier,
the backup, DR, archival.
Across all our
storage classes, you
get instant access to the data.
No need to stage access
to the recovery and deal
with complicated workflows
as to how you're going
to get access to your data.
And then we have a
couple of products
in the multiregional
category, dual
regional and
multiregional, which
will store your data in such a
way that if a region goes down,
then you can immediately
be able to continue
to read data from another copy
of the data in another region.
So providing RTO,
so Recovery Time
Objective of zero on failure.
So if a region goes down, the
multiregion or dual region
is still available for
reads, and your application
can continue serving as
though nothing has happened.
Persistent Disk--
so Persistent Disk
is our block-storage product.
So here you're really looking
to attach a disk to a VM
and run a whole range
of applications.
Traditional sort of
three-tier applications
or high-end database
applications
or even Hadoop and
big-data applications
sometimes run on this
for the performance.
And with Persistent
Disk, today we
have two tiers, which
is a standard tier
and a high-performance tier.
And over the last
year, we've steadily
improved the
performance of those.
For example, for
Persistent Disk SSD,
we've steadily improved
the IOPS that's
available for those
tiers from 60,000
to 100,000 IOPS, all just
as part of the product that
was available.
Today, we're announcing
some new tiers for SSD.
So feedback we
had from customers
was that while
they really enjoyed
the sort of easy-to-use
performance,
there was a couple of
trade-offs that they
found hard to make with
the product that we had.
So what we want
to do is introduce
a new tier that has
lower performance
and is better priced.
That's our new Balanced Tier
that will be available at $0.10
a gig versus SSD's
current $0.17 a gig.
And then we're also going
to introduce an Extreme
Tier for customers,
typically high-end database
customers, that want the very
highest performance starting
with 120,000 IOPS and
eventually going up from there.
And then across all
of these products,
some things that are really
powerful about Persistent Disk
is that it's just
really easy to use.
The disks can be
dynamically resized.
They can be easily moved
around between VMs.
You don't need to
strike your disks
or prewarm the disks to
get maximum performance.
It's all there ready
and available on demand.
One big thing we focus on very
hard in storage at Google Cloud
is just making our
products really,
really easy to use for
customers so that you
can focus on building
the applications
and adding value
to your businesses.
Some of the capabilities
that we have,
high availability, backup,
and DR. So high availability--
you can create a
regional disk which
creates a disk between
two different zones
and create active-active
replications
or synchronous replication
between those two disks, which
is super important if you
want to be able to build
an application that can
survive a zone failure
and recover quickly on
the other side, typically
for something like a database.
And then we also have
controls for being
able to take snapshots
to protect your data.
So you can take a
disk, snapshot it.
The data is stored in
a different medium.
You can store that snapshot
in a different region.
You can schedule snapshots.
So it works well with
traditional backup and recovery
work flows.
And then Filestore.
So as I talked about,
Filestore, this
is for customers who are looking
for a traditional file share
available as a managed service.
Classic use case is
I want to share files
across my organization.
I might be sharing them for
video and image editing.
Might be storing web content,
home directories, et cetera,
or I might be doing large-scale
rendering, video and image
editing.
And so with Filestore,
we offer fully managed
network-attached
storage available in two
different tiers,
HDD and SSD tiers.
Again, goal here is to
give really easy to use,
easy to understand
price/performance
with really great performance.
Very easy to use with
both Google Cloud Engine
for VMs and Google Kubernetes
engine for Kubernetes.
Another announcement that
we're very excited about--
less than a year ago, we
acquired a company called
Elastifile which had a really
powerful set of scale-out file
store--
had a very powerful
scale-out file product.
And we are really
excited to have that now
launching as a new
tier of Filestore
called the high-scale tier.
And this will let
customers scale
to hundreds of terabytes, tens
of gigabytes of throughput,
hundreds of thousands
of IOPS, and really
help customers with some
of those large-scale web
and high-throughput
media-rendering batch
workloads.
So very excited about that.
And then the final area I want
to cover is around transfer.
So having all of these
capabilities in the cloud
is great, but how am I
going to get my data there?
So our customers come to us
with many challenges here.
Sometimes they're
shutting down data centers
and they want to
move to the cloud.
Sometimes they want to do POC.
Sometimes they're
capturing large amounts
of data for analytic
workloads, IoT workloads,
and they want to bring
that data to the cloud.
And we have two
different products
available for customers here.
Transfer Appliance-- so
this is a physical appliance
that you can order from Google.
We will ship it to you.
You can rack it in
your data center,
wire it up, and just load
it up directly with data.
And you can move
up to a petabyte
of data on this single
appliance without having to send
any data over the network.
So this is physical
transfer of data.
And then secondly, we also
have Transfer Service,
which is a software solution
which will move data
over the network.
You can move it between
clouds, within Google Cloud,
and then earlier this
year we announced
that you could move
data from on premises
to cloud by Transfer
Service on premises.
So here you download an agent.
It can help manage the amount
of bandwidth and network
that you want to make
available to the transfer
and then manage long-running
transfers of data to the cloud.
So again, our goal
here is to really help
customers make it
as easy as possible
to bring your data to GCP.
Finally, I really want to
highlight our partners.
So Google Cloud has a number of
amazing first-party products,
but we also have
a really great set
of partners who we work with
on a number of use cases.
We have a lot of
customers who are
familiar with using
these products,
and we to make sure they have
a great experience in GCP.
And also these
partners have products
that do things that we
just simply don't do today,
and we want to make sure that
customers can still have access
to those capabilities
in Google Cloud
even if we don't have them
as first-party products.
So for file, we've done a lot
of work with NetApp, Dell EMC
to provide integrated
experiences in Google Cloud.
And then also with DDN
to have a marketplace
experience for some
high-end Lustre workloads.
And then for backup
and disaster recovery,
so very many companies,
again, use and are familiar
with a range of
different partners here.
And so we've worked a lot
with all those partners
to make sure that we've
integrated closely
with them to make sure they have
a great experience with GCP.
And with that, I would like to
thank you for listening today
and say goodbye.
Thank you.